assisted death in Switzerland means that
you can go to one of the centers and
there's generally two options you can
either take a drink most people die
within about 10-15 minutes it can take
up two hours to die that way life circle
which is where I apply for mine they use
an intravenous method and that's them
quite simply by an intravenous drip
being put in
[Music]
I was born in Manchester
into an Irish Italian
family and I lived in a place called
ankos
was a really bad area at the time and
everybody wanted to move out including
the Cockroaches my dad Vincent pandolfo
he was it was a cracking fella couldn't
watch for a better father and friend
unfortunately just at the last around in
1999 he then developed
MSA related dementia which was
horrendous because it changed him
completely from what he was he was
always a cute fit for nothing well the
MSA put Paul to that because he couldn't
so he couldn't move at all
but it was a kind sharing man it was one
of the high principles but it become the
very antithesis of that it became crude
it became lewd he had lots of day
Terrors night terrors hallucinations
wouldn't know who he was for the last
four or five years of his life he never
called me Alex all the people who was
supporting dad knew him loved him
respected him of you know there's
relations or close friends Etc he
couldn't have had
better care he couldn't have had better
support he couldn't have had that
individual support everything was unique
to him we met his needs as they came up
as best we could and he what he kept
saying to me you know every now and then
he get like Lucid moments and he'd be
pleading with me do something
kill me you must better do something
don't let me down
the only thing that stopped me is what's
frightened to be going wrong if somebody
had said to me if you put this tablet in
his mouth or if this needle goes in in
this place it'll die quickly and quietly
definitely I'd have done that it wasn't
long after my dad died that Mum was you
know poorly and we couldn't figure out
what it was she was suffering repeated
um epilepsy but nothing you know people
think about epilepsy normally think
about somebody shaking and from that
kind of thing but Mum would be just
closing her eyes seconds but she'd be
having hundreds if not more per day
and she was in hospital and my sister
and I was told that um
she's probably got about a month to live
and it wasn't for five weeks afterwards
it was nearly five years so both of them
ended up struggling for five years
um with incurable
conditions untreatable conditions and no
quality of life whatsoever
and they both were fully supportive and
would have had an assisted death are you
able to just explain for someone that
might not know what assisted dying is
assisted death in Switzerland means that
you can go to one of the centers and you
generally two options you can either
take a drink which is that dignitasque
and that normally involves you have to
take a an anti-vomiting drink an hour
before you take your drink and then you
take the drink and that the story an
hour later you take the drink with the
lethal drugs in
uh most people die within about 10-15
minutes it can take up to hours to die
that way life circle which is where I
apply for mine they use an intravenous
method which is a lot more Humane you've
not got that bit of taste you've not got
that well I need to stop myself being
sick for an hour Etc and that's when
quite simply but I need to be in a drip
being put in
and the slide that goes in it's going to
call the capital whatever the term as it
goes and the only difference between
what you have in hospital and what's
there is there's a slide on it and you
have to better remove you know bring the
slide down yourself well so I respect
everything they do in Switzerland what
that does Do Is it discriminates against
people
who haven't got the mobility or the
dexterity to move it so somebody with
locked in syndrome for example
wouldn't be able to have that death
and your personal relationship with
assisted death how did that come about I
think watching both Mom and Dad suffer
gave me you know that that kind of
confirmation but it was right and I saw
what could happen to people
so in March I'd had a few problems I
wasn't communicating right I was having
trouble writing things to people time
became a little bit of an issue for me
and soon after that I was diagnosed with
Alzheimer's
so that immediately that that was okay I
know where this goes oh in his prognosis
his prognosis was three to five years to
live
um although I could live a lot longer
than that I could live up to 11 years
but certainly after the three to five
I wouldn't know who I am or where I am
or what I was doing generally with
Alzheimer's it's
um you can lose again it depends what
part of the brain affects you can lose
Mobility with it
you can lose cognition you can lose
language uh perception's a big one a lot
of people
a lot of people think you know they say
memory it's memory well it's not about
your memory it's about an inability to
perceive to see things clearly it's
um an inability to better process that
information cognitively what can happen
with a lot of people with Alzheimer's is
paranoia
yeah so if you give us something to eat
but throw it away if they want to give
them medication they'll fight it
you'll be in a situation and people will
be telling you that you're wrong
you want to go out and people are going
to hold you down while they're the
instincts really is to find that
and that's that's the kind of impacts
that
um
as well and it's certainly something you
know I do not want to be in a position I
don't want to be in a position where I'm
being violent
to people who attract support me and you
know love me Etc but the interesting
thing with the psychiatrist at that
stage I mean he said to me that um
you don't seem particularly bothered
about it and I said well I expected it
and I've always been quite pragmatic
and one of the first things I'm going to
do is apply from assisted death I've
already got my mind before I even
applied there but because I wasn't sure
I was going to get the what they called
a green light I wasn't sure it was going
to be accepted or not but already it
works out in my mind and took some
practical steps where I could secure
drugs that would kill me fortunate there
that hasn't happened and I contacted
lifecircle and I just said the medical
records when they said that I want to
apply for an assisted death although
you know 60 days about living I don't
want to come next week I don't want to
come this year I just want to get that
in place like an insurance policy but
then I got um
I've got a letter back from them
and there's a few more things I had to
do the first one was I had to write a
piece about my family history
what kind of Life had had what the
relationship with my parents was like
you know that kind of stuff and then
probably one of the hardest things to do
I think if if you've sown mind is to
write why you want to die you know like
I don't really feel like dying today but
we gotta sit down and write that that
could be really testing
I'm I'm
I think it was going to writing Pros I
thought I just don't know what this is
about what during that process I
realized it was a really good strong
safeguard
you know because to sit down right where
you want to die believe me even with a
condition like Alzheimer's and
experience with my parents it wasn't the
easiest thing thing to write down the
next thing I had to do was had to go and
get um a capacity assessment of
psychiatrist
like unfortunately because I'm a social
groups I knew a psychiatrist that I
could go to and then just after that
maybe I don't know maybe about three or
four weeks after a certain information
off I got what they call the green light
so I've got a letter back from um Erica
saying
you've been accepted uh just you know
that it's the only time that you want to
come across that just just let us know
but if the day comes when the day comes
whichever you choose to use I then have
to go and have another psych assessment
because it's a neurological disorder
and that can't be any more than 10 weeks
old before my day so we'll have to
choose my day and at the time I'm going
to get another psych assessment to
establish that I've got capacity
two weeks before the death I have to
have
um
a meeting with a Swiss doctor
and then the day before the death when
you go to Switzerland
um you have to have another one with
another doctor
obviously making the decision to have an
assisted death what in your opinion is
the difference between that and taking
your own life because you mentioned that
you had kind of had that as a backup
plan yeah yeah the massive difference
huge difference so we started running
Secret
it's not something you can share with
the family my ideal is to die at home
and have a party in the morning and
during the day anyone who wants to stay
can stay anybody who doesn't want to
stay well can go so sit around at the
house play some music share some food
laugh hopefully take the Mickey out of
each other and then that'd be perfect so
it's open and it's honest and it's
painless
an assisted death people know about it
is planned in advance you could have
your awake in advance if you wanted to
you you can you keep control of it but
everybody can share it if they wish to
they can have that part and parcel of it
and what you're not doing is dragging
people into it didn't want any part of
that or you could scar for life because
the law isn't here
you know people are either committing
horrendous suicides or partners
uh conducting an act of compassion and
love and taking the partners lives our
husbands and wives brothers or sisters
and ending up in prison
and and doing your friend you
accompanied her to Switzerland yeah um
can you describe her kind of like
journey and how her final few days were
the I mean it's a long journey in an
application it was it was really really
stressful for Dawn and I think she was
getting towards the stage where she
thought it was going to be too late I
mean she she had very very severe
Mobility problems she needed obtain
different joints replacing I should have
become more and more isolated in the
house and on top of all that she started
having brain bleeds Dawn at that time
you need to be in Switzerland for three
days including the day of your death as
you get there you see one doctor day two
so another doctor day three three you
die but dawn said the situated to go for
a week
um like me to the product of the 60s and
we started partying in the 60s and no
one's told us to stop yet so we haven't
so we went away for the week I was in
Bal
where we could we got trams round we got
a chair where it was needed so we
management managed to get her out we sat
in the hotel of an evening
at good food drank fairly decent wine so
we went into the center the morning of a
death I've had a couple of good days
there
I was like kind of playing the music for
it she was up here we got a short a
bottle of champagne she went on the
balcony
um that's really funny I'd never had no
Dawn about sun or eight years never
known to smoke and she's like a chain
smoker and she just said thanks for
everything that you've done he was a
cuddle and everything and then she got
on the bed the intravenous trip was put
in and she was fine we was nattering
away about the things we'd been doing
and and then you have to go through the
questions again so you know like what's
your name what's your date of birth
I'm in Switzerland why have you come to
Switzerland I've come to die do you know
what's going to happen if you know
you've got this I put these drugs in
here you know what will happen yes I
will die you know so it's right to the
last minute you're getting that chance
to sort of say that set and going
so Don said okay well I'm ready now she
moved the slide I had all around on one
side The Other Woman and around old and
on the other side and um Don said I just
I don't want to die alone
and they said don't worry we're going to
hold you around right till the end you
won't die alone
um tell my son that I love him and then
she said Erica thank you thank you thank
you so and that was it she's just like
well a jaw drops straight away so it
must have been fairly fairly quickly and
that's wait for the police to come
that was the police the medical examiner
coming they were with Dawn for about an
hour and they they do everything the
body's well looked into they're looking
for puncture marks they're looking for
any signs of coercion any bruising but
to tell Dawn to stop drinking because we
didn't want the smell of alcohol you
know and advice as though she was drunk
and she hadn't known what she was doing
and that that was it really we then
went back into the into bar into the
center and started falling around people
don't know what had happened but it was
beautiful
and how are you feeling on that day
I
it sounds strange really when someone's
died but I was really happy because
I could make the comparison between what
my dad had gone through and after that
my mum went through
and how horrendous uh was and somebody
had stopped the suffering and the pain
and got what they wanted what they
chosen
and Dawn
Dom's sort of saying that um some of the
interviews it's the only way it could
have been better
is a bit of in her own house
in England you know with more of a
friends who who chose to be there
in terms of yourself if you're like
State of Mind deteriorates is it then
you set a date for yourself
yeah I wouldn't have our provisional
dates in my mind several times so I said
12 I always set a 12 month date for
reviews
um I don't review any longer to be
honest with you I've stopped reviewing
it that's uh I just decided to focus on
on living rather than the possibility of
dying but I used to have things against
if you'd have asked me this question
three or four years ago and I probably
said well maybe the end of this year
and what was basing that on was skills
losing skills and losing knowledge
so I came downstairs I've been taking a
phone call and I couldn't you know I
knew that I'd brought washing down
and I couldn't find so the phone call
finished I couldn't find the wash in I
thought I'd put in the washing machine
which I didn't think I had and I hadn't
uh you know I thought okay so I'm
looking in the living room but I'll put
on the city or something I've left it
upstairs I couldn't find it and it was
about 15 minutes later I decided to have
my breakfast dumped the fridge and my
washing was in the fridge
but so it was little things like that
and I thought if I started doing that
with I started not recognizing people it
wasn't so much the quality of life it
was avoiding getting to that area I
suppose
where the quality of life was bad and
the questionable about capacitor do you
think that that decision to have an
assisted death has affected your outlook
on life
I think what it has done is given me
more time to carry on
in the same way I've always I suppose it
was you know people used to say to me
did you used to be a hipper
and I said well do you know what and if
he wasn't a fashion statement it wasn't
the clothes you wore it was an ethos and
the ethos was you know to accept people
to love people and to have fun
so I think what it has done is I think
my outlook on life has continued to be
what it's been for a long long time
but what it has done is extended that
life period because I'm not dead which I
would have been if I've been for the
Good Will of the people of Switzerland
to support people for other countries
and can you understand why some people
might disagree with the concept
generally
I fully support anybody's Viewpoint and
I think they're entitled to a Viewpoint
whether the opposed to assisted dying
and that is their child I believe in
choice
people who opposers don't believe in
and it's pretty simple if somebody meets
the criteria and they want an assisted
death
then that should be available to them
if somebody meets the criteria and they
don't want an assisted death then they
should be sufficient funding within the
National Health Service to provide
um palliative care for them it shouldn't
be a charity it should be an integral
aspect of the NHS so they should have
palliative care good quality care if
that's what they need for people
watching this who maybe haven't come
across an individual like yourself who's
going to have an assist to death what
would you want people to know from your
story
with everybody's you know if anybody
wants to know any more about about what
assisted day and if they're thinking
about a modern happy to help them and
guide them it's a choice for you to
think about you know if you are thinking
about it you need to think about it
thoroughly
I would tell your family about it
but ensure that you know then it doesn't
matter what they say it's your choice
and that's something to take that away
it's a peaceful death
It's A Beautiful Death and if that's
what you want
and you can afford it which is a crime
you know that's that's something else
that we miss out on the debate that
assisted dying doesn't exist in this
country it's a CIS you know it's the
very very rich I've always been able to
take care of end of life matters but the
socially and economic most social and
economically deprived I've got no choice
but to suffer you know and that's where
the crime is so everybody should be
entitled to it
day comes when you do make the decision
to go and die what would you hope that
your last week day looked like what
would that be for you music drink
and whether you can broadcast so this
and not weed lots and lots of weed
I chose the habit of a lifestyle
[Music]
it's terminal I should make my peace
with that but
it's difficult all my peers have hair
and plans for the future
and I'm just like constricted by this
thing that's trying to kill me my brain